lose sight of these staggering
statistics that were still Russia's
Battlefield setbacks have led it to
cynically targeting energy
infrastructure putting millions of
people at risk of sickness and death in
cold unsanitary conditions
take for example the besieged city of
bat moot where there are no fewer than 7
000 residents one-tenth of the original
population who for the last nine months
have been hiding in basements without
clean water electricity or gas and
minimal connection to the outside world
from the scale of Russia's attacks it is
clear that they have not limited
themselves to military targets their
purpose is simply to terrorize the local
population into submission
that conclusion is the only one that can
be drawn when you look at Russia's
ever-expanding charge sheet of
international humanitarian law
violations
as of the 2nd of April there have been
788 attacks on Health Care Facilities
hospitals clinics medical centers there
have been instances of damages to
educational facilities schools daycare
centers and even nurseries
meanwhile Russia has plundered crops and
agriculture equipment on an industrial
scale destroying grain storage and
handling facilities
according to estimates from the Kiev
School of Economics Russia stole or
destroyed 4.04 million tons of grain and
oil seeds valued at 1.9 billion dollars
in Ukrainian territories during the 22
2022 season alone and the kremlin's
continued in transitions is contributing
to the current backlog of grain exports
besides this Russia has bombed
industrial facilities including the azot
chemical plant risking toxic industrial
chemical release and environmental
impact
it has attacked Ukraine's largest
Refinery at crumb truck on at least
three occasions it has bombed airfields
ports Road and Railway networks
preventing refugees from fleeing the
danger
it has taken out communication networks
affecting Banks internet and cell phones
with residents in some areas now forced
to barter for food and Kremlin strikes
on substations power plants and power
lines have impacted water treatment
facilities leaving cities like mariopol
without water and reliant on delivery
bottled supplies
at the same time Russell has forcibly
occupied and undermined the saved
operation of the zaparicha nuclear power
plant the largest in Europe
as Rafael Grossi director of the general
director general of the international
atomic energy agency has said every
single one of the iaea's crucial seven
indispensable pillars for ensuring
nuclear Safety and Security in an armed
conflict has been compromised he
recently warned the situation around the
plant was potentially dangerous
and sadly so far at least twenty three
thousand Ukrainian civilians have been
killed or wounded although the actual
figure is likely to be substantially
higher
thousands of citizens have been sent to
Sinister filtration camps before being
forcefully relocated to Russia some 6
000 children ranging in ages from four
months to 17 years are now in quote
re-education camps across Russia
the UN as well as U.S investigators have
found that Russia has committed war
crimes with reported evidence of
execution torture and sexual violence in
civilian areas in early April president
zielinski said more than 70 thousand
Russian war crimes had been recorded
since Putin's Invasion the names of
butcher isium have been synonymous with
mass murder the world will not forget
the bombing of the drama theater in
mariopol where 1200 civilians sought
shelter under a giant sign reading
children no matter how much Russia tries
to hide and bulldoze over the scene we
will not forget
even in the territories Russia has
illegally annexed citizens find
themselves subjected to excesses the
worst successes of totalitarianism a
Russian passport is increasingly
essential to access vital Services a
nightmare for those with newborn babies
civilian infrastructure such as
Healthcare facilities are being seized
and repurposed to treat wounded
servicemen
kill lists of Civic leaders have been
drawn up citizens executed in Cold Blood
and consorted attempts made to erase
Ukrainian culture history and identity
we should be clear Mr Deputy speaker the
targeting of civilians and
infrastructure is Central to the
civilian population of Ukraine has not
happened by accident in the fog of War
much of it was planned Russian policy
Russia has fallen we've seen that
handiwork in Syria
in March President Putin himself was
indicted by the international criminal
court for war crimes
but we should also be clear as numerous
credible reports indicate Russia's
morally bankrupt approach might have
been made in the Kremlin but is often
carried out willingly not just by Rogue
units but by the ordinary Rank and file
across Russian Armed Forces
an even clearer picture of Russia's
barbaric approach emerges when we look
at some of the weapons they are using
against innocent civilians I'm not
referring here to the extensive trikes
against Ukraine's electric power network
from cruise and surface to surface
missiles or even the use of short-range
ballistic missiles like the iskanda
which infamously hit the train station
in chromatosk getting 60 and wounding
more than 110 or even the use of two 500
kilogram bombs dropped by Russian
fighter aircraft on that theater in
mariopol
the fact is Russia has used cluster
Munitions with wholesale regard for
human life and civilians they have been
dropped near a hospital in valuda a 9m79
series top chart ballistic missile
delivering at 9 n123 cluster munition
Warhead killed four civilians and
injured ten including six healthcare
workers
it has used smirk cluster Mission rocket
in three neighborhoods and kharkiv
Ukraine's second largest city resulting
in reports of nine civilian deaths and
37 injuries according to the United
Nations
Russia also relies on mass fires
indiscriminate artillery bombardment to
build up areas account for the vast
majority of Civilian casualties injured
or killed
and Moscow makes extensive use of
conventional anti-personnel mines that
improvised booby traps to
indiscriminately harm civilians dead
bodies the homes and vehicles of
Ukrainian civilians and even children's
toys have been rigged as lethal devices
Russia has laid mines remotely and
mechanically covering significant areas
of Farmland with scant evidence of
either marking minefields or warning
civilians about their presence these
minefields will leave a legacy long
after the conflict ends
Russia has used hundreds of iranian-made
Shahi drones to attack Targets in
Ukraine loitian musicians sent on
numerous suicide missions have
repeatedly taken their toll on civilians
last week these weapons struck a
University campus in Odessa and one
small civilians were in the crosshairs
in Kiev
Mr Speaker from the start I've been
cleared clear that our support for
Ukraine is responsible calibrated
coordinated and agile aligned and United
with the International Community we are
helping the ukrainians defend their
Homeland most importantly it is
responsive to Russia's own actions none
of this would have been necessary had
Russia not invaded But now it is about
pushing back their forces and deterring
them from committing yet more crimes by
holding a Russian military establishment
to account for their actions
in December Mr Deputy speaker I wrote to
Russian defense minister shoigu and set
out the UK government's objection to the
deliberate targeting of Civilian
infrastructure and that further attacks
contrary to International humanitarian
law for example the principle of
Distinction codified In Articles 48 51
and 52 of the additional protocol to the
Juniper conventions would force me to
consider donating more capable weapons
to Ukraine so they may better defend
themselves within their territory
unfortunately Russia has continued down
this dark path this year Russia's
leadership has continued to
systematically Target civilians and
civilian infrastructure with bombs
missiles and drones more medical
facilities were targeted in January than
the previous six months combined
it has bombed power facilities in Kiev
car key of Ivana Francis
Odessa and Odessa oblast incidents as
villain casualties have increased
especially areas close to the front
lines such as hershon and buckmut
in January a block of flats and Juniper
was wiped out by a 5.5 tonne rossen
kitchen missile probably causing 124
casualties including 45 fatalities in
March a five-story apartment Block in
zapparitzia was attacked an s-300
missile almost completely destroying the
building and between April 27th and may
Russian forces conductor strikes against
Ukraine using kh-101 and k855 long-range
air launch cruise missile
despite Kremlin claims that it is
targeting Ukraine's military-industrial
facilities one of the buildings struck
was a nine-story apartment building
the Salvo left 23 dead and dozens more
injured last week Russia's shelling
struck residential buildings and on
Monday they bombed a Red Cross Warehouse
full of humanitarian Aid
and Drone footage from Batman appears to
show white phosphorus raining down on
the city Ablaze the use of such and
Sundry weapons which burn at 800 degrees
Celsius with concentrations of civilians
is a contravention of protocol 3 of the
convention of certain Conventional
Weapons
Mr Deputy speak as I've said many times
in the past we simply will not stand by
while Russia kills civilians we have
seen what ukrainians can do when they
have the right capabilities in recent
days 30 shahad drones have been shot
down the Ukrainian Air Force says 23 out
of 25 cruise missiles fried from sea and
land have been downed and we have a
confirmation that Lieutenant General
oshook the Ukrainian Air Force Commander
that even Russia's much-faunted killjoy
air launched Hypersonic missile has been
brought down
and that is why Mr Deputy speaker the
Prime Minister and I have now taken the
decision to provide longer range
capabilities
in December I informed the house that I
was developing options to respond to
Russia's continued aggression in a
calibrated and determined manner today I
can confirm that the UK is donating
Storm Shadow missiles to Ukraine
Storm Shadow is a long-range
conventional only Precision strike
capability it complements the long-range
systems already gifted including High
Mars and Harpoon missiles as well as
Ukraine's own Neptune increase missile
and longer range missions elsewhere
gifted the donation of these weapon
systems gives Ukraine the best chance to
defend themselves against Russia's
continued brutality
especially the deliberate targeting of
Ukrainian civilian infrastructure which
is against international law Ukraine has
a right to be able to defend itself
against this the use of Storm Shadow
will allow Ukraine to push back Russian
forces based within Ukrainian Sovereign
territory
I'm sure the house will understand that
are not going to further detail the
capabilities but while these weapons
will give Ukraine new capability members
should recognize that these systems are
not even in the same league as the
Russian as-24 killjoy Hypersonic missile
or Shah head Iranian one where Drac
Jones or even the caliber cruise missile
with a range of over 2 000 kilometers
roughly seven times that of a Storm
Shadow missile
Russia must recognize that their actions
alone have led to such systems being
provided to Ukraine it is my judgment as
a defense secretary that this is a
calibrated and proportionate response to
Russia's escalations
Mr Deputy speaker traveling through that
country as I have done several times
since the evasion you see the smash
buildings and the piles of rubble where
once there were thriving businesses and
homes for life they reveal the truth of
Russia's Invasion their need is
destruction and their gratuitous
violence their continuing violations
despite warnings of international law
and the deliberate targeting and killing
of civilians they are the visible and
tragic symbols of the kremlin's
desperation
try as they might the Kremlin cannot
hide the fact that their invasion is
already failing they can only occupy the
rubble left by their destruction
at this week's Victory Day Parade
showcased all it did was showcase this
historic failure it demonstrated Putin's
efforts to twist the Soviet Union
sacrifice against the Nazis was an
insult to their own Immortal regiment it
was the facade of power a distraction
from the fortune Invasion the appeal to
Unity while even Russia's own leadership
loses confidence the hypocrisy of
claiming victimhood while waging a war
of their own choosing the reality is
this is the War President Putin's own
choosing at the expense of Ukraine's
sovereignty and its civilian lives Mr
Speaker as you know the UK stands for
values of Freedom the rule of law human
rights and the protection of civilians
we will stand side by side with Ukraine
we will continue to support them in
defense of their sovereign country I
commend this statement for the house
John Healy
yeah yeah yeah Mr Deputy speaker we are
united in our determination to help in
the defense of Ukraine and of our shared
values
and I welcome the defense secretary's
statement his first statement of the
house on Ukraine since January the first
announcement of new weapons to Ukraine
since February we welcome this vital new
military support as the ukrainians
prepare for their expected
counter-offensive
Mr W speaker speaking in The Hague last
week president zielinski said
we're not attacking either Putin or
Moscow
we're fighting on our own territory
defending our Villages and towns
and today's announcement of UK Storm
Shadow missiles will strengthen UK
Ukraine's fight to repel the Russian
forces and to defend against the brutal
attacks the defense secretary has
spelled out in detail today
ask him what are the limitations put
on the use of these longer range
missiles
how have they been integrated with
Ukrainian planes and will other NATO
allies now follow with similar support
Mr Deputy speaker it was six months ago
as the defense secretary has said when
he told this house he was open-minded to
sending longer range missiles and three
months ago in February the Prime
Minister said
the UK will be the first country to
provide Ukraine with longer-range
missiles
so as I asked in my urgent question two
weeks ago why has this taken so long
Ukraine needs all military aid on the
front line now
and president zielinski said last night
and I quote not everything has arrived
yet
we're expecting armored vehicles so can
I ask the defense secretary have all the
10 types of UK armored vehicles pledged
to Ukraine now being delivered into
Ukraine
and the defense secretary is Right Putin
proclaimed in the Victory Day parade in
Moscow this week here is to our Victory
he said
when he can't disguise and he can't
distract from his failure in Ukraine
but despite this Russia is far from a
spent military force and the next few
weeks and few months will be critical
I'm really proud of British military
leadership over the last year on Ukraine
I want in six months time to be able to
say the same we want the UK's momentum
for Ukraine to be maintained and
accelerated
so when will we see the 2023 action plan
for Ukraine which the defense secretary
promised last August why has no
equipment bought by the uk-led
international fund for Ukraine been
delivered to Kiev nine months after this
scheme was set up
when will ministers designate the Wagner
group as a terrorist organization as
laborers argued since February with
support on both sides of the house why
is the government still refusing UK
support for a special tribunal to
prosecute Putin
and who in government is responsible for
leading integrating and coordinating the
UK's backing for Ukraine
now the defense secretary knows that the
government has had and will continue to
have Labor's fullest support in military
aid to Ukraine and in reinforcing NATO
allies
NATO has overhauled its defenses since
Putin invaded Ukraine and the chief of
the defense staff yesterday welcomed new
NATO Regional plans
can the defense secretary confirm today
the UK will fulfill in full
our obligations in these plans and
finally Mr Deputy speaker
the British public are still strongly
behind Ukraine
they want the UK to continue our support
to confront Russian aggression and to
pursue Putin for his war crimes
we must and we will
stand with Ukraine for as long as it
takes
I'm grateful to the right honorable
gentleman for his and his supportive
support and he knows as much as anyone
of all our determination to see this
through and I think it has been a
example example of parliament at its
best over this last
440 or 50 days of this Russian invasion
I will try and seek to answer many of
his questions and and get straight to
the point on on limitations uh obviously
we will not in public talk about if
there are any limitations the the key
here is to give Ukraine that capability
to defend itself uh what I can say is uh
throughout this process we always make
sure we gift uh having examined uh
minimizing escalation and provocation
unnecessarily uh to the Russian state
that is not the business we are in we
are in the business of helping Ukraine
defend itself within its Sovereign
territory and of course it is easy to to
forget that of course none of this would
be needed no deep strike capability
would be needed if Russia withdrew its
forces to the other side of the Border
back into Russia and every Russian Force
would be safe after that but of course
that is why we are seeking deep fires
within Ukraine for example because
Russia have invaded so far deeply into
another
country on integration of the plane of
stormshadow is a air-fired missile uh he
is correct it is of course not easy to
take a British uh French missile and
incorporator on a uh a former Soviet or
a Russian aircraft now that has been one
of the reasons for the time is working
out if it is technically feasible and I
would like to pay tribute to our
scientists and our technicians who have
done an amazing job not just with this
type of capability and actually other
scientists across Europe who have
managed to produce integration of
Western weapons into Russian equipment
or indeed some Innovative capabilities
at a speed that I often question why I
can't have that speed when I
domestically try and commission some of
those capabilities so there are lessons
there but that is one of the areas I'm
not sure there is many other powers with
similar weapon systems for similar
support there is however a drive by many
uh
allies to deliver further deep deep
capability High Mars is obviously 80 to
90 kilometers but also there's another
American system that was gifted a few
months ago forgive me I can't remember
his name that has a longer range and
also in the international fund one of
our requirements in the second round is
deep fires deep strike the ability to do
that as well
it took long Mr WWE partly because of
technical feasibility taking effectively
a sort of fifth or fourth generation
weapon system and putting it sometimes
on second or third generation aircraft
is not easy and we will see they are not
uh you know I'm not going to comment on
when they we expect these to be used but
nevertheless they have yet to be tested
and and we will soon find out or maybe
in the next few weeks or months we'll
find out uh to the extent that that has
worked but that takes time uh secondly
as I've always reassured the house I
wanted to calibrate our response we need
to make sure that we do these things uh
in in line that helps Ukraine further
its capabilities uh you know gifting
these earlier when we were unsure
whether they're going to say work and
indeed without any form of offensive on
the horizon uh may not have made a made
made them vulnerable but B may not have
made the difference that we're all
trying to achieve so so all I can say
now is having technically cleared the
hurdles and as everyone talks about a an
expected counter offense now is the
right time to gift these uh to Ukraine
and they are now going into or are in
the country uh itself
um on momentum I would say that no one
should doubt any of our momentum here
yes the media comes and goes and covers
different aspects of of the world and
Sudan comes along but I think if you
look at the the government's track
record and either its gifting it's
training into Flex which we went from 9
000 last year we're training 20 000 this
year around the country in the United
Kingdom the gifting of the tanks at the
beginning of the year our momentum
continues and on that question about
what has gone in the country I'm
certainly confident I know that all our
tanks have gone in into the country many
of our Spartans many of our armored
vehicles uh I don't know if every single
one has and I'm happy to write to the
right honorable gentleman but the big
ones like the tanks they are all in
country they have trained exercised both
here but then in Ukraine and I know that
the Ukrainian force is using them so far
uh have enjoyed them very much and and
talk very highly off the challenges and
that also goes to the as90s that have
not only been put in but I think they've
also been used as well I think there's
another lesson there they seem to get
excellent availability on the as90 so
the lessons to be learned in our
capability uh on the Wagner group
designation Mr Deputy speaker of course
uh prescription prescribing an
organization is a matter for the home
office done via Collective right round I
can't comment on when and how those
things happen we've obviously heard the
calls from both sides of the house to
prescribe it Wagner is a thoroughly uh a
nasty uh organization not only from what
we see in Ukraine but what we see in
West Africa and indeed we've seen in
Syria and does pose a threat to the
United Kingdom and her allies either
directly or certainly indirectly and it
is a group that needs dealing with
although Mr pagosian seems to be making
himself deeply unpopular with the
leadership and the Kremlin at the moment
and if I was him I wouldn't stand in any
open windows at the moment uh if I'm
dealing with Mr Putin but nevertheless
Wagner is here and we have to deal with
it as well on the regional plans um I am
trying the regional plans are over 3000
pages long uh and uh uh also written in
NATO speak which probably makes them the
equivalent of 12 000 pages long when you
try and decipher them it is very
important that we try and both make our
commitments that meet those plans and
also support others if they don't have
that capability because the strength of
NATO will be can it carry its political
determination into a military plan that
makes a difference and deters because
that's what we're really about deterring
Russia or any other aggression so
there's a few more weeks and months to
go but I'm absolutely waging my wading
my way through the 3000 pages to see uh
where in the action plan and after this
a statement I'm off to the Army on
Salisbury Plain to discuss exactly that
Sellwood you very much Mr Deputy speaker
because I very much welcome this
statement I've just returned uh recently
from Ukraine there's massive
appreciation for what Britain has been
doing and continues to do not just from
the government with its lethal aid but
also from the British people with the
humanitarian support that's been gifted
uh as well those huge anticipation about
the uh counter-attack that's likely to
take place but also message which I hope
the secretary would agree that it may
require second third or fourth
counter-offensive to take place this
isn't going to end simply when the
ukrainians decide to push forward and we
should expect Russia to go ugly to use
unconventional systems in response on
Storm Shadow could I welcome this yet
again Britain's stepping forward is the
Americans are the Americans going to
match with attackers and could he spell
out the fact that there's still a
request for jets to be gifted as well
and finally Trump last night refused to
say that he wanted Ukraine to win this
isn't material Factor because he could
necessarily win the United States
election next year and this might be
what Putin is banking on thank you
okay
um yes the guy that my right honorable
uh friend uh characterization of the
counter-offensives is is correct I don't
think there is a single you know one
last thrush and everything's over by uh
thrust by Christmas I think this is a
matter of uh Ukraine quite rightly uh
finding and exploiting as any good
General wood uh uh weaknesses or indeed
opportunities so I think we should
always manage our expectations that it
that it is not all over by Christmas
and when you have a Russian army that
doesn't mind sacrificing hundreds of
thousands of its own people you're up
against not such rational leadership
that would recognize as anyone else
would do that the game is up already
when you lose 10 000 armored vehicles
then over 250 000 dead or wounded of
your own soldiers uh you know most
people would have recognized the game is
up so that is uh one of the big
challenges look there are other
obviously weapon systems that Ukraine
asked for and the attackers is a
well-documented uh capability we're
pretty confident that the Storm Shadow
will plug some of that Gap and
definitely deliver the deeper range that
that high miles used to achieve when it
was at eight kilometers but uh the
Russians after the suffering significant
losses to high miles obviously worked
out and moved Beyond range rings so we
think the Storm Shadow will absolutely
help the ukrainians make that difference
as well and on the uh on the U.S
president the U.S president today is
President Biden I have a good
relationship with him so does the
government as well they have stood firm
87 I think billion dollars worth of
donations they put their money where
their mouth is they have huge amounts of
effort gone into their support I I lived
in America for a few years all my
parents did I know that the decent and
good people of America would recognize
that their rights are just as important
as the people's rights of Ukraine and
whoever comes next to the president
their constitution upholds rights I
think that is what will unite them and
I'm confident that whoever comes next
will continue to support the battle
uphold human rights
thank you Mr Deputy speaking can I thank
the Secretary of State for a very
detailed uh statement and Advance sites
of it and to assure him that the SNP
contain and will continue to condemn
Putin's unprovoked invasion of a
peaceful Democratic neighbor and the
strongest possible terms can I join uh
with the labor front bench and asking
for once again the UK government to
formally prescribe the Wagner group as a
terrorist organization a good deceptive
State take back to his colleagues in our
departments that we would like to see a
plan to support Ukrainian refugees to
seek damages against the Wagner group in
the UK courts and could he also given
that he mentioned Iran uh could we I
would also add that the government
should be considering uh prescribing the
terrorist organization the irgc as well
and could see Secretary of State uh tell
US president zielinski said that Ukraine
is constrained by delays in the delivery
of armored vehicles and what action plan
is the government along with its allies
uh making sure that those armored
vehicles are delivered to assist in
those efforts and finally could the
Secretary of State comment on reports
that India Imports of Russian oil has
risen tenfold in 2022 and what did the
government plan to do alongside allies
to ensure that oil products originating
from Russia do not reap record profits
I'm I'm grateful to The Honorable
gentleman and I'm grateful for the SNP
support on this I think we all recognize
what Ukraine is fighting for in it and
it appeals to all of our decency and how
we must stand up for it he's uh
suggestion of wagon group in the
financial penalty or the suing of the
courts is an interesting one and it does
slightly remind from my previous day's
security minister prescription is an
important tool but it rarely unlocks any
more than a sort of um a sort of brand
you know a labeling of something the the
thing that will go for wardner will have
a bigger impact will be suing in the
courts I suspect given mercenaries if
they don't get paid don't hang around
and uh you know seeking damages through
our amazing court system whether that is
in Scotland or or the or London uh is
where it's world renowned for being fair
and respected uh has a long tentacle so
uh I I listen to his suggestion well I
can't advise the victims of Wagner group
I certainly think uh hitting Wagner in
the wallet will certainly probably have
a stronger method even though uh
prescription I hear is also wanted and I
also listen to the irgc call you know
Iran is absolutely supplying Russia with
drones it can't hide it it can't pretend
it it is supplying Russia with drones
and of course Russia in return is
funding the Iranian the irgc to make
those drones in that industry and that
poses a wider threat to the region
whether that is uh to Yemen Saudi Arabia
the houthis Iraq where we to Iranian
drills being used already and there's no
good shall come of it shall we say on
that as far as delays go one of the
assistants we do we have people in
Poland and Slovakia and Romania helping
coordinate delivery and making helping
the logistics of it we stand by to help
any other Nation do that and I'm very
happy at our next meeting of colleagues
either at NATO defense ministers or
other to find out who's having a
difficulty and we stand by ready to help
the one of the things not written about
what we do in Ukraine some of the great
work we've done is in things like
Logistics flying aircraft to pick up
people's donations and bringing them
back to the hubs all of those people are
heroes to me they're members of the RAF
will be flying airplanes we do it we do
it uh often in a sense not secretly just
you know the media don't seem to want to
write about it but but I know about it
and I think it's a really good work by
doing it so we'll keep the momentum
we'll keep the suppliers coming in but I
think we should all recognize and where
if any of you has visited the Ukrainian
training uh you know there's a lot of
hardship still to come
Alicia Cairns
speaker I welcome the delivery of Storm
Shadow because we must do all we can to
evenly odds for our Ukrainian friends
who faced a well-armed terrorist State
however I am concerned that at this
point what we have not managed to
suffocate Putin's War Machine yes we
need to deliver military aid but we also
need to make sure that we suffocate the
finances that allow people to continue
to wage this war so can I urge my right
of a friend to Lobby the chancellor to
establish an economic Ramstein of G7
treasury ministers or Allied Nations who
can come together and make sure that
economically we are doing what is needed
to stand up the phenomenal war effort
being led by my writable friend and all
of our allies around Europe
I think it's a good idea and I'll
definitely pass that on to the
chancellor I mean they have done already
work through the G7 with the oil cap but
but she's absolutely right that Russia
needs funding it needs to to sell its
oil and gas I mean currently there are
reports that it sells at a huge
discounts to China and India in order to
get it uh through there
um but and I also know that both the
foreign office and the treasury work
tirelessly to close any loopholes that
brought their attention whether that's
brought to attention by members or
anyone else in law enforcement agencies
I think Russia has shown itself of being
Adept in these loopholes but we do see
in the Russian industrial base it is now
struggling in some of its rearming of
its equipment because so much of its
subsystems seemed to have come from the
West that now it's finding it hard
definitely to resupply itself
John speller thank you speaker the
announcement about new Munitions to
Ukraine is very welcome but we also need
reassurance that his department will be
able to restock so can he tell tell us
what they're doing to ramp up and
sustain production capacity including
Supply chains not only to support
Ukraine until the end of this conflict
but also to ensure
restocking for our own armed forces
and he he is right uh uh that we have to
keep restocking ourselves some of the
restocking has started in the in-laws
they remember the very first gifting
that has started a few months ago uh the
also the areas of the low and high
velocity anti-aircraft missiles on 155
I'm hoping to be able to inform the
house in June that we would have placed
a long and enduring contract in the UK
to replace our 155 shells which of
course one of these conflict exposes
that you need those type of Fires
available so it is important it's
important the treasury gave me in the
Autumn 560 million for some of that
refurbishment but also other funding at
the latest budget which I will of course
make sure is spent in keeping our forces
refurbished Francois
we have led Western Europe in supplying
kit to the ukrainians ab administered by
mod equipment defense equipment and
support it should be noted but we
haven't yet sent Jets
despite the fact we've got a squadron of
trans1 typhoons sitting in a hangar and
despite the fact that President zelenski
very publicly called in Westminster Hall
recently for us to do that
Checkers take notes from his own
experience that when this long-awaited
countertop counter-attack begins those
Ukrainian brigades must have local Air
superiority over the battlefield in
order to succeed and what is left of the
Ukrainian Air Force is far too small to
do it on their own so can I ask him
specifically what are we doing a to send
Jets
and B what are we doing to encourage
other Western allies to send them big
29's f-16s or even a-10s because it
would be a tragedy literally if the
counter-offensive ran out of momentum
because it lacked air support
my right on my friend is right to talk
about how you may maintain momentum and
needing air support because of course
while the Russian army has been very
very badly decimated its Air Force a
significant part of its Air Force
remained in a good condition and
therefore it is vital that that Air
Attack potential is is minimized on
particular Jets uh we offered as you
know to ukrainians uh training on
typhoons I recently received a letter
turning that off as a request and asking
us for support on the F-16 which of
course we don't hold however I would
encourage anybody to gift f-16s to help
the ukrainians and in and in the
meantime we already use some of our our
funding and support to buy spares for
the likes of the migs and everything
else if if that is required because the
other Challenge and this year is going
to be sustainability a lot of equipment
has been gifted and huge numbers of
Russian tanks have been captured we can
refurbish and sustain them then of
course that's the best way and quickest
way for Ukraine to continue its fight
and so we need to keep its Air Force
flying but however on the F-16 I'm very
happy to encourage any of my colleagues
to donate them and if they do we'll
happily move them
get forward thank you Mr Deputy speaker
and on behalf of the liberal Democrats
uh I'm very grateful both for advanced
site of the statement and for its
substance
two days ago the Washington Post
reported that the UK quote now appears
poised to send Keith the long-range
missiles that the Biden Administration
has long denied it
what is the United States government's
position on the UK's decision to supply
this deep strike capability
thank you the issue I take the Wall
Street Journal is is the US have not
denied
Ukraine longer range they put in the
high Mars and indeed some other West
assistant the difference was the
attackers which is a different type of
munition it's a very it's not a it's not
a sort of deep strike the Storm Shadow
has the capacity to hit below ground
it's like a it can go into a bunker type
thing and an attacker is more of an area
weapon so it's a different weapon system
you know the Americans have been clear
on on its donations or not at the moment
considering that donations as far as the
use or the donation or gifting of Storm
Shadow the United States have been
incredibly supportive on the United
Kingdom's decision to do so board
can I thank my right honorable friend
for his very sobering statement the
scared
sheer scale of atrocities against
civilians is horrific it's heartbreaking
that over 23 000 civilians have been
wounded or killed
um last month UNICEF told us that now
the number of children who've been
killed is over 500 and we must not
forget the thousands of children who
have been kidnapped by the Russian child
catchers
given the attacks on medical facilities
and the level of casualties come my
right honorable friend update us on what
medical support the UK has been giving
to Ukraine
yes my right Uncle friend sitting next
to me the minister for defense personal
and Veterans and himself a naval surgeon
has been incredibly proactive in
coordinating and supporting that met a
number of times with the Ukrainian
Surgeon General and and Willard again
soon we have provided training and
Equipment uh certainly in the healthcare
for the medical including Rehabilitation
but also alongside in the Department of
Health has been able to support and I'm
very happy to write to the uh honorable
lady with the details of the sort of
pure civilian medical help and
assistance we have given but that often
is around things like generators
ambulances and other medical supplies
welcome
Deputy speaker the defense secretary
himself has said that the conservatives
have hollowed out and underfunded our
Armed Forces so why is the defense
secretary still pushing ahead with
further cuts to the British army by ten
thousand troops and two billion pounds
real-time Cuts in day-to-day mod
spending which means less money for
forces pay Recruitment and Families
Mr Speaker it'd be good to The Honorable
lady actually quoted me correctly the
and say the conservatives I said
successive governments including her own
for the last 30 years have hollowed out
the armed forces and that's why we need
to rectify it's why we got 24 billion
pounds recently in an extra 5 billion at
the last election not so not last budget
not only to refurbish but also to
modernize Armed Forces get the quote
right next thank you
long Shadow is a potent weapon so I
cautiously welcome the announcement
today on the basis of what the secretary
of state is reported to the house I'm
also reassured by the undertaking that
Storm Shadow will only be used to
prosecute targets inside Ukraine why
because NATO's aim has to be to reject
Russia from Ukraine not to wage war
against Russia
my point is this can I also ask him
please in the same way that Challenger 2
preempted the deployment of Abraham's
and leopard too could we assumed in this
particular case that the deployment of
stole Shadow like preempt other medium
and long-range weapons being deployed
from other NATO Nations and also could
he specifically answer please what it
will take for f-16s to be deployed
well um first of all my honorable friend
um there are other nations with similar
but not exactly the same type of weapon
system and I have seen already our next
bidding round for the international fund
will include deep strike and long range
fires that we will procure through this
International fund which includes Sweden
and Norway and the Netherlands
Etc on that fund so there is there is
more to come from both the market and
depending on what gifting and what we
would say is that the assessment of the
gifting we've so far planning to give of
Storm Shadow and Mr Deputy speaker I
won't say for operational reasons the
exact number is currently enough to
satisfy the Ukrainian demand for that
capability we'll keep that under review
to make sure we can make the difference
Shannon the deputy speaker hi very much
welcome to suggest it's a step in the
day and I can also command them for a
very very strong and determined
leadership it reflects what we all want
them to do and he does it very well
thank him for that President this very
morning that Ricky needs much more time
to prepare to launch the highly
anticipated counter-offensive against
Russia as the military still needs the
Western Aid that has been promising that
the secret has indicated some of those
things that are happening to prevent
further loss of light what are major
steps will the foreign office take to
deliver the much needed announced
vehicles to assist Ukraine push back
Russia as they intensify their talk
their tax and then ask or blast
I'm grateful to The Honorable gentleman
I I think none of us should uh
underestimate the political weight on
the shoulders of the president of
Ukraine it's easy for us here in our
safety of London and behind an alliance
of 30 in NATO to forget that he is going
to have to make a decision at some stage
in this year to send men and women of
their Armed Forces across minefields
towards machine gun posts to take back
their Sovereign territory and I think it
is you know there will be no easy way to
predict when they'll do that and he is
has to balance that with also an economy
deliberately destroyed by Russia that he
is also going to have to balance so I
wish them well in that we will continue
to support them to the end in my view I
you know it's what I believe and we
stand for we will keep supporting them
uh what I can say is if he delays
because he's waiting for the equipment I
would understand that fully we'll do
everything we can to make sure
everything gifted is in the right place
at the right time so when he makes that
decision those men and women have the
best chance of survival
here's Mandel hey thank you Mr Deputy
speaker and I I draw attention to my
entry in the register of members uh
interests I welcome a my right honorable
fence statement and announcement and he
set out a list of atrocities which
surely uh shames Putin and Russia I've
seen for myself in Ukraine how evilly
and deviously land mines and other booby
traps are contrived in order to cause
the maximum a casualty and a danger to a
civilian so am I right honorable friend
confirmed that the UK government will
continue to support the day-to-day work
of the Halo trust and the mine Action
Group in the removal of uh these Minds
because they are the imminent threat on
a day-to-day basis to so many civilians
yes the Halo trust is an amazing
organization I think first founded under
the Soviet occupation of Afghanistan and
that's where its pedigree comes from I
met recently some people who had been
working in the Halo trust in Ukraine
it's ongoing now but long after this is
over I know they will be there and the
government will do everything it can to
support them whether that's through the
ministry defense or the foreign office
and other departments I'll compare it
we can thank the Secretary of State for
his statement before 2022 the Ukrainian
army uniform had not been adapted for
women's bodies today women form about 23
of the Army in Ukraine and roughly seven
thousand are fighting on the front line
does the minister agree that The Bravery
of these women should be recognized and
what support has the government provided
Ukraine to ensure that female soldiers
have the equipment that they need
the normal lady makes a really important
point and indeed when my honorable
friend the member for wrexham did her
report about women of the Armed Forces
one of the main recommendations for our
Armed Forces was making sure we're
buying equipment for women and not just
a sort of for all in that sense and and
we have started to do that and as such
become our industry has become some of
the industry leaders in that area and as
a result some of the work and gifting to
Ukraine reflects exactly that to make
sure they get something specific for
them that makes it easier to live in
those trenches and and survive thanks
for prompting me um speaker because when
I go to school to play it in about 25
minutes I shall make sure we get a catch
up with the training of Ukraine and find
out if they're still getting those
uniforms
cool thank you thank you Mr Speaker can
I thank Myron or friend for the update
he's given us today and for all of the
work he's doing which is absolutely
tremendous I spent a very short time
just a few days in Ukraine early this
year and saw the the devastation
um
coming from the the illegal Invasion
um he touched on operation interflex is
he able to say any more about how that
work is progressing
yes I took the first lady of Ukraine to
interflex last week and we have nearly
700 foreign troops helping from
Australia New Zealand most of the
Scandinavians and the Dutch alongside
about 750 British troops we have trained
9 000 plus last year in our on course to
do 20 000. this year we've now expanded
at the request of ukrainians not just to
do basic training but we're now training
non-commissioned officers and indeed
have just started last week platoon
commanders courses so we're starting in
the development of the low level
leadership that you need to start to
rebuilding your Armed Forces we expect
to continue to get requests we've had
another request to expand the training
and we are absolutely in the middle of
it I'll be having a conversation about
that this afternoon and I hope to have
more to announce the house later
I'd like to thank the Secretary of State
for defense for his statement today and
for responding to questions for over
three quarters of an hour
Royal ascent
I have to notify the house in accordance
with the Royal Ascent act
1967 that his majesty has signified his
Royal Ascent to the following Act
higher education freedom of speech Act
2023.
before I call the Secretary of State to
make his statement on transport Mr
Speaker has given a statement that he
has repeatedly made clear that the house
should be told first When government is
making any important announcements and
he is extremely disappointed that
there's been extensive press coverage
this morning about these developments
Mr Deputy speaker that's actually a very
helpful uh point for the you to have
made on behalf of Mr Speaker and as you
know I completely agree with that this
of course is um as as I've seen some
chuntering from over over the other side
but they should understand this once we
notified uh first group of my decision
there was obviously a market sensitive
information that they were obligated by
law to disclose to the stock exchange as
soon as the markets opened this morning
and that meant the decision was in the
public domain we issued a press notice
but other than that no other information
has been put into the public domain and
uh I've therefore kept all of our
remarks until the house was able to be
updated but in Market sensitive cases I
know Mr Speaker will understand that
there are certain things that do have to
be disclosed to the outside world and
aren't able to wait until being notified
to the house
um so Mr Deputy speaker let me start by
thanking the entire transport industry
and officials across government for
their professionalism and hard work over
the last weekend tens of thousands of
people travel to Windsor and Central
London for the coronation of his majesty
King Charles III and her majesty Queen
Camilla getting the public around
efficiently and safely took months of
planning and preparation and special
thanks must go to Great Western Railways
for putting on additional Services as
well as Network Rail and Southwestern
Railways who facilitated the biggest
movement of military personnel by the
rail industry in over 50 years for the
coronation it meant people from across
the UK indeed around the world were able
to unite in celebration during what was
a truly historic moment
Mr Deputy speaker in my most recent oral
statement to the house I made clear the
government's commitment to deliver a
railway that works for passengers
businesses and of a taxpayer and where
services are not up to scratch we're
holding operators to account and where
there are systemic weaknesses in the
industry we're pushing ahead with reform
so I wish to update the house today with
our progress starting with the future
operator of the trans penine express
contract
since I took off is I've been clear that
first tpe service levels have for too
long been unacceptable passengers
including memory honorable and right
honorable members across this house have
faced significant disruption including
regular cancellations and pool levels of
communication the underlying reasons
behind this vary but what's clear is the
twin challenges of covid and Industrial
action have left their mark
first TPS driver training backlog now
stretches to nearly 4 000 days which
means that at any one time it can only
draw upon 80 percent of its total driver
Workforce adding to this a breakdown in
relations between the operator and the
driver Union as left and all told there
simply haven't been enough drivers to
run the planned timetable inevitably
passengers have borne the brunt facing
cancellation rates of up to 23 on Monday
to Friday services and gaps in services
on some routes of up to six hours that
clearly isn't good enough
a point I have made directly with with
first group which owns first tpe and
which my honorable friend the rail
Minister has made in weekly meetings
with the rail North partnership where
transport for the north jointly managed
first tpe's contract with the department
for transport
we will always hold operators to account
for matters within their control Mr
Deputy speaker
we'll give them a chance to put things
right
but despite a recovery plan put in place
since February there remained
significant challenges underpinned by as
less distinct lack of cooperation
to achieve the performance levels I
expect that passengers deserve and that
the northern economy needs it's clear
that both the contract and the
underlying relationships must be reset
and I have therefore decided not to
renew or extend first tpe's contract
when it ends on the 28th of May
instead I am exercising my operator of
Last Resort duties and directly awarding
a new tpe contract to a public sector
operator who will operate it on my
behalf
as transport secretary my obligation
first and foremost is to secure
passenger rail services on which tpe
passengers can rely that requires a new
approach one which the olr is best
placed to deliver in these circumstances
and most significantly it provides an
opportunity to reset relations between
management and all stakeholders from
passengers to trade unions
I've also asked my officials to review
services in the north to help Drive
efficiency and find better ways to
deliver for passengers across the region
and I will ask all interested parties
including the northern Mayors and
transport for the north to engage with
the government on this work
now whilst today's decision will be
welcomed by many and whilst it shows a
government alive to the concerns of
passengers as my honorable friend the
rail Minister and I have made clear it
would be misguided for anyone to think
this is an instant solution the problems
first TP phase won't disappear overnight
any operator facing industrial action
and a union coordinated ban on overtime
working will struggle to run a reliable
service
so I invite those who have long called
for today's decision including unions
Northern Mayors and colleagues across
the house
to work constructively with me and my
honorable friend the rail minister to
fix the underlying problems and help
return service levels to where they
should be and Mr Deputy speaker the olr
is just the next stop on the line it's
not the Terminus station and once market
conditions allow we intend to subject
this and indeed all contracts both
private sector and those under the olr
to competitive tendering Mr Speaker
there will be some unfortunately who
used today's decision to further their
ideological ends to argue that this
somehow justifies all rail contracts
being brought under public control that
would be a mistake the majority of
taxpayers do not use the railways
regularly but they could be saddled with
the huge costs of nationalization only
to inherit the indices problems with no
plan to fix them nationalization is a
sound bite not a solution and this
government will always be guided by the
evidence to help make the best decisions
for passengers which is why earlier this
year having seen the noticeable
improvements on of anti-west Coast I
resisted calls to bring the franchise
into public ownership I extended
Avanti's contract by six months a
decision Vindicated Mr Deputy speaker
with Avanti calls cancellation rates at
the end of March falling to 1.4 percent
from 13.2 percent in January and
continue doing to improve despite
ongoing challenges Mr Speaker let me now
turn to Industrial action for months the
rail Minister and I have worked hard to
change the tone of the dispute and help
facilitate fair and reasonable pay
offers for workers but in negotiations
with train operating companies the rmt
in azlef are refusing to even put those
pay offers to a vote of their members
despite rmt members who work for Network
rail voting overwhelmingly to accept a
similar deal earlier this year instead
the rmt have balloted for you more
industrial action and along with azalev
both have cynically called strikes that
will the network during the
Eurovision song contest this week we're
hosting Eurovision because last week
year's winner Ukraine can't it will be
an event attended by displaced
ukrainians that have fled Putin's war
and we've just our house has just been
hearing about that threat Mr Deputy
speaker so at Beggars believe why unions
have chosen to disrupt such an internet
symbolic event one that not only
presents the united front against
Russia's aggression but it shows
solidarity with Ukraine's resistance so
my message on behalf of Fed Up
passengers is to say to the union
leaders call off your strides put the
fair and reasonable pay offers to a vote
and give your members a say on their
future but wiggle without Union support
the industry must modernize to avoid
permanent Decline and Mr Speaker Mr
Deputy speaker we're building
Unstoppable momentum towards rail reform
as I set out in my Bradshaw address in
February I announced that Derby will be
the location for gbr's at new
headquarters and today I can report
progress against the commitment I made
to extend single leg pricing to the rest
of the lner network tickets will go on
sale from May the 14th for travel from
June the 11th and it means lnr
passengers will benefit from simpler
more flexible and better value ticketing
removing the frustration that a single
ticket can cost almost as much as a
return
Mr Deputy speaker in conclusion since
becoming transport secretary my Approach
has been to listen to The Experts weigh
up the evidence and make decisions in
the interests of the traveling public
today's announcements show a government
tuned into the concerns of passengers in
the north unafraid to take tough
decisions to deliver better services and
relentlessly focused on modernizing our
Railways whilst protecting passengers
from the effects of industrial action
that's what the British people deserve
it's what we're delivering and I commend
this statement to the house
Louise Hague
Mr Deputy speaker and can I thank the
Secretary of State for advanced site of
his statement Mr Deputy speaker after
years of comprehensive failure after
tens of millions in taxpayer cash has
been handed to an operator so clearly
not fit for purpose after needless
damage has been wrought on our northern
economy and more than six months after
Labor demanded it the Tories have
finally accepted that they can no longer
defend the indefensible they have seen
the writing on the wall and the only
question passengers will be asking today
is what stopped the Secretary of State
taking action sooner how on Earth did it
take this long let's just be clear about
the failure that until now has been
allowed to go on unchecked this operator
has broken records for cancellations
almost one in five Services last year
did not run fewer than half the services
were on time and it's not just been an
issue for the last few months as
ministers claim but for years
seven years ago well before covid
transpennine Express had exactly the
same staff shortages they suffer from
today they failed to address the issues
that passengers are still experiencing
that they managed to keep this contract
for so long to be told only months ago
they were in line for an eight-year
extension is extraordinary
but Mr Deputy speaker the difficult
Truth for the Secretary of State today
is this
his decision shines an unforgiving light
on the fractured Railways his party are
responsible for
this endless cycle of private operators
having to be taken over shows the rail
system is fundamentally broken
the comprehensive failure of trans pen
and express is not a bug in the system
it is a feature of it
since the conservatives came to office
the East Coast franchise collapsed and
was taken over Northern rail followed
then London and Southeastern
Mr Deputy speaker for the conservatives
to have nationalized one Railway may be
regarded as Misfortune to have
nationalized four demonstrate something
much more fundamental the privatized
model they have rigidly lauded in the
face of all evidence is collapsing
passengers see Services get visibly
demonstrably worse while hundreds of
millions in taxpayers money is handed to
shareholders without the faintest hint
of competition
how much longer will people be asked to
rely on a system that's so routinely
fails
his decision today must just be the
start the Secretary of State now needs
to show the leadership that has been so
sorely lacking to stop casting around
and blaming everyone but themselves
will he set out to the house the
immediate plan to address the
long-standing issues of recruitment
training and rest day working and what
steps is he taking to end the industrial
dispute that has now been ongoing for
over a year can he confirm when he last
held talks with the employers and the
unions to bring the dispute to an end
strike action is imminent but he still
has opportunity to avoid it
can it really therefore be the case that
he has not met with the unions and
employers for more than five months
if that is correct it is a truly
shocking dereliction of Duty the
Secretary of State's decision today must
be the start of something more
fundamental he can choose to continue
with the charade to entrench the
fragmentation that his proposed reforms
will deliver or he can accept that he
has been wrong and bring the remaining
operators into public ownership he can
end this broken system that is failing
passengers bring track and train
together speed up fair reform and
deliver a simpler unified Railway
today's decision makes that case more
obvious than ever
Services have literally been never been
worse and too long the Tory solution has
been more of the same the entire country
should not have to put up with this for
a second longer it's time for
fundamental change and it's time to
deliver the rail service that Britain
deserves
[Music]
well first of all um Mr Deputy speaker
the point that The Honorable lady makes
about the timing is very straightforward
the contract that TB has expires on the
28th of May and I noticed Mr Deputy
speaker this morning The Honorable lady
in another flip-flopping of Labor's
policy knows that the contract expire is
a sensible point at which to take
decisions because because because
that's the point that she's going to
nationalize rail Services is waiting for
the contracts to expire so actually I
think that's a that's a rather faux
complaint on her more
um substantive points or on in on
Industrial action I'll set my position
up very clearly when I took this job I
changed the tone of the debate I met the
rail union leaders and I ensured that
they were it was for the employers were
facilitated to make fair and reasonable
offers on network rail a fair and
reasonable offer was made of pay and
reform importantly reform Mr Deputy
speaker which how these offers are being
funded that was put to the members of
the rmt who work for Network Rail and it
was overwhelmingly accepted not my words
the rmt's own words 90 turnout 76 in
favor uh fair and reasonable offers have
been made by the train operating
companies under their umbrella group The
Rail delivery group two rmt members
working for the train operating
companies broadly comparable offers in
value also with reform the rmt for
reasons that I really don't understand
has refused has refused to put those
offers to their members Mr Deputy
speaker so offers are on the table
they're waiting to be put to their
members and they won't put those offers
to their members as left have an offer
on the table which would take the
average salary of a train driver from
around 60 000 pounds a year to 65 000
pounds a year so I've been doing my job
offers are on the table offers are on
the table they need to be put to the
members of those unions so they can make
a decision
the focus though Mr Deputy speaker
that's my final Point uh from The
Honorable is not really surprising
because of course the rail unions have
donated a total of just over a million
pounds a million pounds to the labor
party or labor office holders over the
last five years the General Secretary of
azlef is chair of labor unions the group
of unions a facilitate Affiliated to the
labor party and sits on Labor's national
executive and The Honorable lady said
that she would be working hand in love
with you about asliv what I would say to
her what I would say to her what I would
say to her is what you said should do is
suggest to them that they use this
opportunity to do rest day working to do
rest day why I have I have said those I
have made those points to the unions but
if she's working hand in glove with them
and tell them to call off their strike
at the weekend stop
focusing on damaging the Eurovision
contest we host for Ukraine
and work in hand in love with them and
if she fails to do so people will see
she's all talk and no action
thank you Mr Deputy speaker my honorable
friend will know that the TP level of
services caused absolute Havoc for my
constituents other people struggling to
get to College people struggling to get
to work so can I congratulate him for
his leadership and for this decision I'm
really really glad that he has taken
this step and I know my mum will be as
well as she was stranded by trans penile
Express a few months ago
um I understand it's not a silver bullet
it will take time and of course he will
have my support but can he say a little
more about when he expects the level of
service to reach the levels that my
constituents in scunthorpe deserve thank
you
she of course has over a a long period
raised these issues on behalf of her
constituents and I thank her for doing
it as I said in my statement Mr Deputy
speaker we're not going to see overnight
change I think this was a this is an
important decision to reset those
relationships how quickly we can improve
services will depend on the response of
others to those reset relationships and
the use that the new management of the
company uh how it uses that I hope we
will see uh early results but I have
been clear to the house both when I made
my previous statement on Avanti and
today that there isn't a magic wand but
I hope this is an opportunity to reset
those relationships and get things
moving in the right direction
thank you much uh Mr Deputy speaker back
in January I said to the new Minister
that in the priority transplanting
Express could not point to a single day
when it ran at the emergency timetable
the emergency timetable the improvements
have been glacial and the government
have finally taken actions through many
of his uh called for some time ago a
transparent blamed anyone but themselves
including workers and the unions for the
chronically poor service truth and truth
is it remains there was before an action
had to be taken it is good Mr Deputy
speaker to see another English based
operator nationalized slowly but surely
the UK government is falling in
Scotland's footsteps now he said
nationalization is a sound is a sound
bite not a solution this despite it
would be the actual solution the
government has gone for uh but I would
generally say to him that private
privatization has been aborig not a
benefit and of course we welcome the
government Foreign
Service and would note that this means
the anti-nationalization Tory Park is
now nationalized for rail services in
five years there's confused as the
leader of the opposition who plays to
nationalize the railway then it seemed
to recently backtrack
um on it it's at the very least
um hit signal failures
over 10 of people in the UK support
private ownership of the Railway even
among 20 voters they're only 13 support
privatized Railways UK government's
privatization obsessions out of state
not only with the wider public but also
their own voters desires so isn't it
time for the government to listen to The
Experts listening to the workers and
listen to the voters and end the field
experiment of privatization and finalize
to Deputy speaker despite involving a
dispute sorry involving unions and the
Scottish government were resolved very
quickly yet Scott's passengers have
faced disruption due to this
government's unwillingness and inability
to resolve disputes so why does the
Secretary of State think that Scotland
has managed to resolve strikes so much
more efficiently than this government
it was it was too
substantive questions there Mr Deputy
speaker so let me deal with both of them
first of all I'm our accept is welcome
for my uh decision I think I think there
was a I think there was a welcome there
um on his point about
um industrial action if you're going to
reach a deal it does take two to reach a
deal uh from our side of it fair and
reasonable offers have been put on the
table and I said they are fair and
reasonable they're broadly in line with
the offers that were made to the rmt
staff that work for Network rail which
when they were put to the members of the
Union were accepted overwhelmingly with
a 90 turnout and 76 in favor similar
value offers with reform have been made
to rmt staff working for have been
working for the train operating
companies and have not been put to the
members so the clear outstanding issue
is not a new offer but it's for the
offers to be put to the members of the
trade unions to enable them to make a
decision and there's an offer on the
table to train drivers as well who work
who are in the aslift union that has not
been put to their members either and
they said it would take their average
salaries to 65 000 pounds a year I think
that's an offer at least worth putting
to them that's the outstanding piece of
work that needs to take place
um and as we've done our bit of of that
job the reason why the Scottish
government reached
conclusions I think was because it caved
in it's not delivered reform and I think
it's overpaid with taxpayers money
there's a balance to strike here about
fair and reasonable offers that are fair
to the workers in the industry the
passengers that it serves but also to
the taxpayer and that is a
responsibility I take very seriously
David Mundell thank you Mr Speaker I've
repeatedly called out in this chamber
the appalling levels of service which my
constituents at localby station have
received over a long period of time from
transparent Express and the failure of
the management there to address those
issues so I very much and my
constituents very much welcome this
decision because they had no confidence
that transpennine would be able to turn
the situation down as he says this is a
reset where all the stakeholders
including those in Scotland can come
together so that passengers can have the
level of service that they both need and
expect can he expand a little on what he
will be doing to ensure that that reset
can produce those results
gladly and and my right honorable friend
indeed has raised this uh issue on a
number of occasions
um so just to start first of all my
officials will of course be working with
uh officials in the Scottish government
and I this morning spoke to uh Kevin
Stewart MSP who's the Scottish transport
minister to explain the decision to
explain that we would be working with
the Scottish government uh on looking at
the services that are currently in olr
cover the whole of the north of England
and obviously cross-border Services as
well which are very important to my
right honorable friend I also spoke with
the elected Mayors in the north of
England that cover these areas to
explain the decision and also to confirm
that we were working closely with them
on the best possible pattern of services
going forward and I hope that
demonstrates the government's intention
to use this reset moment as
constructively as possible and I hope
everyone else responds in like manner
Paula Barker
Deputy speaker and I refer the house to
my register of Interest as a proud Trade
union member
it's really interesting to hear the
Secretary of State talk about renewal
dates because in March 2023 when the
shambolic Avanti West Coast contract was
renewed 9.1 percent of its services were
canceled in the same month only 6.6 of
transparentine services were canceled so
why is he only punishing some operators
for their failures and not others and
isn't it time to fix the broken system
once and for all and put his own
ideology aside and embraced Labor's
plans to bring our Railways into public
ownership
well I think I answered that question in
my statement if the honorable lady was
listening uh in when I made my earlier
statement about Avanti I resisted pools
to bring it into public ownership for
very good reason they were delivering on
their uh recovery plan and I said I at
that time had confidence that they would
continue to do so when I extended it by
six months since I did that their
cancellation rates caused by them have
fallen to 1.4 from the 13.2 January in
January they're continuing to improve
demonstrating that that was the correct
decision and I was right not to listen
to calls from the party opposite to do
the opposite to Edward Lee
Builders of people living in Grimsby and
cleethorpe to access London via donkster
VIA transpennine surely undermines the
importance does it not of our campaign
led by myself my excellent honorable
friend here for cleethorpes to get a new
service run by Ellen ER direct to London
from Grimsby and cleethorpe through my
constituency and Market raisin Lincoln
much better route we're actually
delighted with his excellent rail
Minister who's been listening to us but
we want the rail Minister's boss to give
him full support and get this service
not least because rural people demand a
better service
grateful for my um honorable friends uh
question and I know he's met with the
rail Minister uh with colleagues to talk
about these services and the rail
Minister has been keeping me uh updated
about it I know further work is going to
continue and we will of course do our
best as we always do to try and uh keep
my honorable friend Happy yeah student
diving thank you Mr Deputy speaker the
secretary of state will of course be
aware that there are many uh
constituents across the country who
don't have access to any rail services
at all and of course that's the case for
residents in the east of Cardiff where
I've been a long-term campaigner for a
stations we built at some melons indeed
benefit the constituents of modern on
the front bench from Cardiff Central as
well but there are crucial works that
need to be done to make that a reality
including relief lines on that on that
line and of also the connection that he
visited the proposed connection between
uh Cardiff Central and indeed Cardiff
Bay to improve Services there would he
meet with me to discuss how we can move
those projects along and get improved
roles services for my constituents
a little gentleman quite rightly speaks
that's for his constituents and I
remember when we announced the the
leveling up fund bid for the connection
between Cardiff Central and Cardiff Bay
he he welcomed it on behalf of his
constituents and the uh City he
represents uh either I or the rail
Minister will be very pleased to meet
him to discuss what more we can do to
deliver Services
um I'm very keen that we deliver
improved rail Services across the whole
uh of the United Kingdom and we'll do
what we can to to help Martin Vickers
thank you Mr Deputy speaker I welcome
our art honorable friends decision uh to
have renewed the franchise would have
been to reward failure uh the
transparent service between cleethorpes
and Manchester uh over the last 18
months on a good day could be said to be
unreliable on a bad day totally
appalling and I would very much agree
with my right honorable friend that now
is the time for the unions to step
forward and let's get around the table
and reach agreement on rest day working
so that my constituents can have a
proper hourly service between clear
thoughts and Manchester which is what
transparentown should have been
providing for the last day 18 months
yeah but I am I thank my honorable
friend um for that comment again he's
another colleague who's been raising uh
these issues on a regular basis
um it is important to recognize this is
an opportunity for people to um respond
accordingly what what's disappointing Mr
Deputy speaker my honorable friend
referred to the opportunity for the
unions to agree a new rest day working
contract of course the the cynical way
they behave is asleff agreed that rest
day working contract and then
immediately said it was going to be
taking action sort of a strike and
withdrew any cooperation at all now I
hope that they will respond to this
decision in the right way it's an
opportunity to reset those relationships
and do what we're all supposed to do
which is deliver a better Railway for
the passengers that use it and I hope
they take that opportunity if they do
they will find a willing partner in me
you're a hob house it's a deputy speaker
rail companies across the country are
failing rail customers Fair hikes
cancellations and delays gwr which I use
between bath and London is no better
between July and October 2022 gwr saw an
increase of 179 of delay compensation
claims compared to the previous year the
government has promised to fix the
system and create Great British Railways
in law when
well I'm very familiar with the gwr
service Mr Deputy speaker I use it
frequently myself there have been a
number of problems on the western route
not actually to be fair uh often caused
by gwr but calls by Network rail but I
accept that inconveniences uh passengers
just the same partly why we're bringing
together track and train together under
gbr and I will continue having that
focus on performance and in fact I'm
seeing the leadership team at Network
rail today and in fact one of the things
that we're going to be talking about is
their performance on the western routes
and I will raise the honorable lady
specific concerns with them this
afternoon
Daniel kalginski thank you Mr Deputy
speaker I have spoken to the rail
Minister on many occasions about my
concerns about the service of Avanti
trained and also Arriva trains Wales but
when many services are canceled we are
informed that they are due to staff
illness or sickness or and people not
turning up to work why are there such
extraordinary high levels of sickness in
this sector and what is he doing to work
with trade unions and the bosses of
trained companies to understand that and
to deal with it
so my little friend uh raises some very
good points on behalf of his uh
constituents and he's recently had a uh
an update by way of a written answer
about some of the issues uh on his
services for about Services being
withdrawn by uh uh transport for Wales
and also some of the infrastructure
issues and I hope that was helpful on a
specific question about Workforce I've
made it very clear Mr Deputy speaker I
want a thriving successful Railway with
increasing patronage and increasing
Revenue coming in through the fare box
and I want high quality well-paid jobs
we're not going to see those things
happening if we don't drive up patronage
and we're not going to see that if
there's continued industrial action so I
repeat what I said if the unions put the
pay deal to their members let's see what
the members think the sooner we can
settle these disputes and have the rail
service being successful in attracting
new customers the better for everyone
those working in it and those using it
peacock
Mr Speaker the secretary of state says
the government evaluate the evidence to
do best for our Railways yet
transparently Express is now the fourth
operator in five years to have its
contract canceled for failing passengers
when will he accept the evidence shows
that the only way to fix the broken
system is Labor's plan to bring our
Railways into public ownership
well The Honorable lady I've actually
talked about the evidence The Honorable
lady is not right when she talks about
the other services that were brought
into olr they they weren't uh brought
into the operative Last Resort because
of their failures for passenger Services
it was largely on financial issues uh
that they were brought in this is the
first one actually where it's been
brought into the olr
um for failing to deliver
um appropriate passenger services and as
I said I don't take decisions for
ideological reasons I look at the
evidence and I will always be motivated
by making the right decisions for
passengers that's what these services
are designed to deliver and that's what
I will always put first
thank you Mr Deputy speaker um I welcome
the announcement however this should
have happened months ago in terms of the
operator of The Last Resort as a regular
user review of anti-west Coast Mainline
Services have improved but they're still
really really bad so just how many more
Second Chances do have anti deserve and
how many uh when is the Secretary of
State going to say enough is enough and
stay with contract away from them so so
on Avanti I mean I don't think the
honorable gentleman is right the
services have improved they're not
they're not they're not everywhere they
are completely where they need to be but
they're now up with the rest of the
industry and they do need to continue to
improve I made that clear when I
extended their contract I said they had
made progress and they needed to
continue it uh clearly I will have to
make a decision later this year about
what we do when it comes up for Renewal
again and it will depend as it did last
time on their performance I hope they
will continue to keep increasing their
performance and demonstrating that they
can deliver for passengers and that will
be important when I come to make that
decision
Mr Deputy speaker the minister mentions
of anti in his statement and the
improvements that they are apparently
making but my constituent Zoe contacted
me to see that she's been trying to book
an advanced single standard premium
ticket from London Houston to Glasgow
for weeks she needs it for the end of
this month and while she can book her
ticket to London she can't come back
home again because those tickets haven't
been released yet what kind of service
is that if people can't predict how they
can get home how can that possibly build
confidence in the service and have
people traveling Well I obviously don't
know what's happened in this specific
example if the honorable lady will give
the details to my honorable friend the
rail Minister we'll look into that
specific case but if you look at their
performance overall they have made
considerable progress both early this
year but also since I extended their
contract and as I said in answers the
previous question I want to see that
performance continue to improve on
behalf of constituents just like The
Honorable ladies
Jeff Smith
Deputy speaker my constituents many of
my constituents in South Manchester will
be breathing aside of relief that this
finally
um light at the end of the tunnel in
relation to the transpennine services
um
um but as my honorable friend set out so
well earlier on that they're not the
only company that are failing passengers
he says that he doesn't think public
ownership is is the answer so what is
the answer to these failing operators
when will we see the government come
forward with a proper plan for the
fundamental reform and Improvement of
these operations that we need
well yes I I set out
um in my George Bradshaw address earlier
this year uh a clear plan uh which was
published in the white paper
um on bringing together track and train
in gbr so there is a guiding mind to
look at the overall structure of the
industry
um and also I announced the headquarters
uh of GBL will be in Derby which was uh
welcomed and will continue making
progress to deliver on that plan which I
think is the right plan to have a
successful thriving rail industry both
for uh passenger customers but also
importantly for Freight customers and
we're going to set a Target later this
year to move a certain amount of freight
off of our roads onto our Railways both
good for Railways and good for our
environment
then Diana Jones Thank you Mr Deputy
speaker across the Humber we welcome
this announcement today but I think many
Fed Up passengers will say after years
of terrible service why has it taken so
long can I just ask the minister to
confirm as well that this will mean that
the penny pinching and mismanagement by
tpe of our beautiful Victorian Paragon
rail station in Hull and the five-year
Saga of the substandard toilets they
installed will be over and will the
minister also agree to meet with Humber
MPS and businesses to discuss the rail
electrification which is still missing
from the integrated rail review and
projects like the ins installation of
the line between Hull and York
so first of all I'm grateful The
Honorable lady has welcomed the decision
today and and it is a moment where I
think we can reset relationships to
improve services for her constituents
um on her specific question about the
toilets at the station I don't have the
details to hand but her that request and
her specific request to meet with MPS
from the Humber area I will make sure
the rail Minister responds accordingly
and gets that meeting set up at which
she can discuss that issue and other
colleagues can discuss appropriate
issues for their areas Rachel Hopkins
thank you Mr Deputy speaker uh
privatization has led to the uh breakup
between not just track and train but
infrastructure such as Luton station uh
I'm thankful that the rail Minister
visited he's seen it for himself and he
knows it I'm very passionate to stand up
for my constituents that we will soon be
getting our lifts installed but the
leaks in the roof are have impacted the
small local business as well as the cafe
services and commuters cannot get their
cup of tea in the morning
despite that the small businesses moved
back into the leaking roof part in order
to survive so can I ask the minister to
please press upon Network rail to at
least fix the leaks in the roof at the
station if nothing else
the the minor friend the rail Minister I
know visited that as she set out and I
think went to that very Cafe
um and uh as she knows as she knows
um we're very keen on making sure we fix
the roof or the sun is shining so I will
talk to the rail Minister and see if we
can make some progress on making sure
that that station is in an appropriate
state for her and her constituents yeah
John Trickett
instruments in your are brushed off with
the fact that public transport is so
badly damaged that it's not available
I think that question is so far removed
from reality I don't know where to start
the the on the first on the first point
um actually the response to what's
happened here is that the contract has
not been extended and it's been taken
into the operator of Last Resort because
I think it's necessary to reset those
relationships on a second point about
trade Unions that's fundamentally wrong
I when I took this job I decided it was
important to change the tone of the
debate I met all of the uh rail union
leaders I have a perfectly constructive
relationship with them I facilitated
fair and reasonable pay offers we
settled the dispute on network rail
which was overwhelmingly accepted by
members of the rmt there are fair and
reasonable offers on the table for rmt
members working for the train operating
companies and the train drivers are all
I hope for is that those offers get put
to the members of the trade unions the
people the general secretaries are
supposed to work for and allow the
members to make a decision on what I
believe a fair and reasonable payoffers
thank you very